chris pratt here i'm currently playing
dan forrester in the tomorrow
i'm here with buzzfeed to rank every
character i've played
in my illustrious 20-year career in
hollywood here we go
number one we've got bright abbott from
everwood versus
winchester che cook from the oc
bright abbott from everwood i did for
four seasons and then winchester che
i did uh in 2008 for one season i'm
gonna have to choose bright abbott
on that it was my first really big break
in television
it allowed me to buy my mom a house i
loved uh the work that we did on the
show
right vanquishes che oh dan forrester of
the tomorrow war
versus scott hatteberg and moneyball
i'm gonna say dan forrester only because
we're promoting the tomorrow war but
scott hatterberg probably would win
but i'm giving dan the win uh scott
hatterberg's a real person
a real baseball player that role was
amazing i got to work with brad pitt
bennett miller the movie went on to get
nominated for an oscar
probably because i was in it and i got
to work with phillip seymour hoffman it
was
an amazing experience i loved it i got
to wear a real major league baseball
uniform
so of course normally i would fix guy
hatterberg to win but since we're
promoting the tomorrow war
where i play dan forrester i'm gonna
have dan forrester advance
joshua faraday from the magnificent
seven oh versus jim preston
from the critically acclaimed passengers
now
although most critics are going to be
upset about this
i'm going to pick josh faraday from
magnificent seven i got to work with
denzel
i got to work with antoine fuqua i got
to play a cowboy shoot a sick shooter
that was pretty sweet i've always wanted
to be in a western and i got to be and
passengers
it was an amazing movie an extraordinary
experience i got to work with
j law i'd like if they could both
advance but there can be only one so
i'm gonna have josh faraday from
magnificent seven advanced
justin lenahan what the who's that oh
zero dark thirty
yeah right i forgot my character's name
was justin in another film that was
nominated for an oscar
here we go that was dope it was my first
uh sort of foray into the world of navy
seals
i got to do some extensive research met
my best friend to this day on that
job and it is an amazing movie peter
quill guardians of the galaxy
hey it's tough that's a tough one i'm
going to go ahead and move forward with
peter quill on that because that was a
real
life-changing role for me very grateful
for that so
just edging out the character who
apparently is named justin lenahan quill
takes the win oh in a battle of animated
characters
barley lightfoot from the oscar
nominated onward
you know i'm really like into mentioning
all the movies i've done that have been
nominated for oscars versus emmett
burkowski in the lego movie was that
nominated for an oscar
i think it wasn't that year and that was
the year i was like okay you guys really
got that wrong god that's tough
both of those movies are so good i'm
gonna go with them emmett brakowski from
the lego movie
he moves forward next we have oh andy
dwyer
parks and rec that's gonna be tough to
beat him uh andy dwyer versus
fletcher flemson of bride wars my wife's
favorite movie of all the movies i've
been in
she thinks bride wars is the best you
know everyone's entitled to their own
taste honey
it's our anniversary today so for that
reason i'm gonna have fletcher funds and
beat out andy dwyer
no no i take it back andy dwyers is too
icon andy dwyer for the win the
five-year engagement
alex isla hauer that was cool he was a
chef i got to work with
jason siegel on that i really kind of
fell in love with that guy on that movie
he's amazing
versus disgusting donald and oh what's
your number i'm going to go with alex
eilhauer he's a chef
and i get to learn how to sing in
spanish
[Music]
i don't remember how to say it anymore
but anyways jurassic world owen grady
versus paul in the film her a lot of
people don't know this but i was in the
film
her as much as i did love her and i love
joaquin and i love spike
owen gradient jurassic world it's kind
of a fan favorite so i'm going to move
forward with owen grady
that brings us to the eight man bracket
we got bright
abbott versus dan forrester dan forester
for the win tomorrow war
next we have uh josh faraday versus
peter quill i'm going with peter quill
guardians of the galaxy all day long
next uh emmett
versus andy dwyer oh that's tough
i'm gonna go with uh andy dwyer seven
seasons love my parks and rec cast and i
still have a lot of people that come up
to me and say that that's the favorite
character i've ever played which is very
flattering and then alex isle howard
versus owen grady i'm going owen grady
so now we're down to four
pretty iconic characters i'm so lucky
man i have a great career i'm really
thankful
we've got andy dwyer versus owen grady
both of them are pretty
epic and iconic i'm gonna go with owen
grady they both have theme park rides
but owen grady's is a little bit better
dan forrester versus peter quilt dan
forrester is a character that you may
not even know
unless you've seen the tomorrow war dan
forester versus quill
all right i'm gonna go with quill i'm
not gonna lie i'm going peter quilt so i
got quill
versus grady jurassic world versus
guardians of the galaxy
i mean the only winner i can think of is
america i'll let you decide
who's the better between those two one
is an unstoppable force
and one is an immovable object and the
truth is
the two cannot co-exist in the same
universe it's just an opportunity to
show my forearms
who has two thumbs and is a total douche
thank you for playing rank your
characters with me i'm chris pratt the
tomorrow war opens on
july 2nd only on amazon prime video
you